alright Evan Carmichael welcome tell
edition of ask Evan today we're
continuing with our challenge series
where we're partnered up with Telus
talks business and looking at answering
questions from their community to help
them grow their business the last one we
did was here how to know when to move
out of the pilot beta phase that was
from Jeremy who wrote in today we're
going to answer another question from
one of our Facebook fans here it's from
a cool so he wrote in saying I have a
question for ever in the challenge
series I work from home and love the
Flex however grow business maybe get an
office if we have staff I prefer not to
get an office but it feels like we may
have to also with local staff I have to
lead by example and working on 25 trying
to keep the lifestyle love or expand and
he is from mo cool apps com so thanks
for the question McCool a great question
i think one that a lot of entrepreneurs
face is a think about their business and
how they want to grow it up and i'm
going to give you three suggestions that
I hope will help you make a decision
number one do what you love your
question ended with should I keep the
lifestyle I love or expand you shouldn't
have to pick between doing something you
love and something else do what you love
you'll not only enjoy your business a
lot more you'll get much better results
as well if you're going to the office
every day hating the commute hating the
fact that you have to be there for set
times hitting the extra overhead you
have to pay do you think that your
environment is going to bring out the
best in you some people thrive in an
office environment they like feeding off
the energy of others and they might be
too lazy or unproductive if they stay
home but just because other people have
an office to grow doesn't mean you have
to a lot of people struggle to search
for what they love if you've already
found it don't lose it
you
number two embrace the genius of the end
in Jim Collins his book built to last he
looked at companies that have stood the
test of time and found a way to
persevere when all their competition
have fallen apart these are companies
that have thrived for an average age of
a hundred years like 3m Procter & Gamble
Sony Marriott and so on one of the
characteristics of these companies had
in common was that they embraced the
genius of the end what this basically
means is that when these companies were
faced with a question that seemed the
pit one idea against another they found
a way to do both don't look at keeping
the lifestyle you love or expand instead
keep the lifestyle you love and expand
once you frame were thinking around
solving that problem new ideas and
opportunities will come to you that you
didn't consider before
number three build the remote team over
the past few years I've got in the
complete opposite direction of your
thinking I have an office in Toronto and
used to have a team here I thought it'd
be easier to manage a team when I could
have them in front of me and the
communication level would be much higher
my team was your young hungry and
motivated and as a result also had a
desire to travel and see the world we
were faced with the choice do I keep
them on board forcing them to stay in
Toronto or do I let them go and find a
job somewhere else we embrace the genius
of the end keep working for me and go
travel and see the world as a result
they love what they do work hard to
finish their assignments and created a
work-life balance that keeps them happy
now I'm the only one in Toronto my team
is spread out across Canada the US
Europe and Asia communication is
trickier but manageable and it means
that I don't have to be in the office
either if I don't want to be you can
have a full-time team of remote workers
who work just as passionately for you or
more than a local set of workers good
luck McCool I hope this has helped and
keep us posted with your progress thank
you for joining me for another edition
of ask Evan and our Telus talks business
challenge series if you liked the video
you want to see more please give it a
thumbs up and makes me to do more these
videos for you guys and I'd love to hear
what you have to think if you want to
leave a comment under the video I always
check those out and try to respond to
everybody who writes in if you have a
question and would like to be featured
in our next challenge series feel free
to leave it in the comments section
below and I will consider you for the
next challenge and hopefully I can make
a video to help you answer your business
problem so thank you and you'll see you
on the next episode
you